in the fight against the virus Senegal
is deploying bulldozers this informal
market was where people came for food
clothes or a cup of tea destroyed in a
matter of minutes by government which
wants people to stop gathering in public
spaces vendors retrieve what they can
before the market is disinfected the
chemicals used are meant to protect them
they're told protect them from what
wonder street vendor Dion Nasser
more threatening than the virus is the
uncertainty ahead he says you know
people are selling out selling you know
doing their activities because they
cannot stay at home because when they
when they stay at home they cannot
actually food free feed themselves
announcers neighborhood where people
live in close proximity social
distancing is a luxury confinement is
not an option for those struggling to
survive while President Macky Sall shows
people how to wash their hands in a
country where most people don't have
access to running water the government
is trying to impose a state of emergency
and a curfew in order to limit movement
of people this is the case not just in
Senegal but in other African countries
to several infected patients have
escaped quarantine and isolation units
in hospitals in Mauritania Gambian
Zimbabwe this crisis is revealing the
level of trust people have in their
government and health services before
the outbreak already people here were
struggling with access to water and
electricity now with even more
restrictive measures they struggle with
trying to make ends meet half a billion
people across sub-saharan Africa live on
less than $3 a day some already face war
now they face a potential deadly virus
say the children says cases of kovin 19
have gone up by 500 percent in just a
week we need to act now and we need to
maintain support for existing
humanitarian response plans on which 100
million people depends if such funding
is diverted the consequences could be
catastrophic
cash draught African countries are
calling for debt relief in a hundred and
fifty billion dollars in emergency
funding with the number of cases
multiplying daily time isn't on their
side nicholas hawk owl jazeera dakar